are you chase me oh no no hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to dead dreams now this game is
incredibly highly rated everyone says
that it's terrifying everyone says that
it's a well-crafted story and everyone
says that it'll leave you scarred now
that being said I don't know for certain
but I have not played what what Oh is
something wrong Audrey did I miss some
Audrey where are you going
did I miss some I did I miss something
what did i just miss what's with this
blood rip spray paint
okay we shouldn't be on the tracks
[Music]
I'm very confused that's probably fine
I've heard worse things in sewers hi how
you doing dude okay good yeah trained oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no what happened
Audrey Aaron lame where are you guys
[Music]
I have no idea what's happening and I
have no idea why it's happening and I
need someone to tell me the answers to
those new questions before I lose it in
actually I maybe maybe I was overacting
maybe I actually don't need the answers
to those questions maybe I'd be fine
with all the answers to the questions
that I'm asking hi oh hey you okay well
what's your name uh ID you know I don't
know I'm a little confused as to what's
happening here a lot to take in lot
right away I don't
[Music]
now fully cognizant of the happen
stances of these locales I'm not the
only one that's confused right you guys
at home are confused also I need to be
so aggressive oh but that's not your
hair color you're blond alright man were
forget Thomas Thomas is my brother I
don't wanna forget him hey you're blond
alright guys good talking to you I'm
gonna go in here oh I'm in the void
alright I'm in the void okay I'm getting
like this weird I've got this weird
almost like cry of fear vibe because I
just dropped you in the middle of
nowhere and you don't know why you're
there
why am I here why was I chased down by a
demon train what was that what did I
just see I have so many questions I have
no answers to those questions I have no
idea what's happening
I am so as that's normal that's normal
normal normal stuff happening normal
normal normal normal stuff no normal
stuff I'm going to have a seizure what
is happening why is it shaking why are
you shaking
shaking hi hi okay you might be dead you
might be just be a headless dead okay I
really can't see now a real foggy some
fog in the air I don't like that oh I
can't move I'm not moving
what is that am I am I owe me
mommy ma boo well I don't know what's
happening
Oh back to the tutu's toot-toot-toot at
least this screen isn't shaking no more
at least I have that this seems like
stairs but apparently not am I just
gonna go back to the beach am I to lay
down and die I imagine I'm in some kind
of a purgatory Oh guys I don't think
it's a good idea you can always say no
and go home I'm just worried about you
oh sure you've already been there a few
times and it's totally safe the
abandoned subway tunnels filled with
rats doesn't particularly sound like a
safe place I mean what do you want to
show us anyway that's a secret so how do
I know if it's worth to go down there
you'll just have to believe us listen I
don't care about rats or anything like
that but these stations were closed for
a reason right that's why I wanted to
ask yeah supposedly wait Thomas you
don't want to go either
no no I was just curious what was the
reason behind it have you really never
heard about no that's odd well whatever
there was an explosion some sort of
chemicals I guess who's from an
underground laboratory people were
talking about some secret experiments
right which means that the station could
still be contaminated
except it's not and how do you know that
alright alright listen I understand your
worries but I assure you that what
you're gonna see is absolutely worth it
besides Audrey you could use this time
to take some photos okay I guess you're
right sure are you kidding me just one
more this is like the sixth time we've
stopped for you I thought you didn't
like this place
are they always like this you'll get
used to it
Wow so how do you like it it's beautiful
and imagine what we'll show you is gonna
be a hundred times cooler this way wait
do you want us to go over this bridge or
you can cross by water
nothing's this bridge was built to stay
here for years decades even just look at
this fine rusted metal it's all rusty
and I have a really bad feeling about
those gaps don't judge a book by it's
cover so who wants to be first no one I
could try I guess here's our hero Thomas
no I'll be fast
god there's no need to show off all
right here I guess I don't have a choice
in this I guess I'm gonna go all right
cool
cool guys are okay follow me I guess
okay hooray okay now it's my turn
be careful Jesus what the hell are you
doing Liam stop it
see it's fine there's no uh okay you
okay Liam I think he's in shock has he
hurt Liam to hear us I'm fine thank God
and what do we do now there's another
route it's longer but safer Liam do you
remember where the station is sharp All
Right see you there guys okay I guess
we're on our own then there really isn't
a whole lot of explanation going on
which is fine by me you know I'm not one
for like a bajillion pages of exposition
but you know I just like a who what
where and why might be convenient uh I
have no idea I mean I'm not complaining
it's all it's all fine hey dude this is
blog one news blog oh dude blah blah
dude dude is blocked is blah
Oh what was what where where where wait
a minute wait Aaron
Jesus are you all right wait what is
happening haven't we guys why did you
stop
I guess that's hot there was an
explosion chemicals I guess that's odd
there was just explosion but what's odd
it was from an under Tori people were
talking about some secret experiments
right it was from an underground
underground underground ground
underground underground could shin-bi's
dated which means that I'll be staminate
it is that some kind of a joke guys
except it's not alright alright listen
sure I understand your worries but I
understand that you that you're worth it
I assure you're going to see it is
absolutely worth it if we're it worth it
worth worth oh hey what is happening I
would like to know this is one what
where is everyone
I don't understand where is my head
going on my super yourself alright okay
[Music]
what is any of this what is happening I
love it I love I'm so into I but why I
ride let's keep going baby what is this
what is this penis statue I don't know
okay cool
back into the weird world oh hi
photograph all right the cube all right
I am so so mystified by this I'm getting
like earthbound vibes like witch's house
vibes like cry of fear vibes I it's such
a I don't even know I want to know so
badly hello October eek where Flores Oh
Flavio malva omnis Jam Dorito none tuna
rubriz or or sure oh hi what is
happening I would like to know Audrey
Liam Aaron where is everyone calm down
you'll see them soon what are you doing
to me what can I remember Thomas who's
that Liam Liam he doesn't hear you I
want to see them Thomas tell me do you
like to suffer hey I'm not a masochist
I've been through this many times I like
to see the limits of what my body can be
pushed through I am NOT a Mascis do you
like to suffer to see your friends die
no of course not
why have you then just stay here and do
not climb up the tree I'm gonna climb
that tree so hard and so fat
me to the tree where's the tree is a
dead add I bet it's straight I'm
hi who are you I'm here to serve her
grace but how did you get here what's
your name
this doesn't matter EMM am I dreaming or
something
not exactly yeah it's all too real to be
a dream okay then where are we
we're in the gardens the garden yeah I
see that but where are we
it's a safe place that's all you need to
know sure safe from what
all right can you at least tell me
something about this tree we're not
allowed to touch it sir and you've never
asked yourself what's up there why would
I
Her Highness clearly said that it won't
do any good
who cares what she says did she steal
your memories too alright I'll go up
then wait don't I won't just stay here
and do nothing
believe me sir it's dangerous out there
you sure maybe I'll regret it and maybe
you're right but they would do the same
for me have you ever had friends a
Majesty is my friend and yours too of
course she is Meera so this thing's name
dude guy man dude all right I got this
tree now see around Snoozeville saved oh
cool umm oh this can't be good if I if I
touch this it's gonna be very bad I can
already see oh here I go
I touched it Morse code Ott's remember
got it it's remember that's remember
okay remember remember what remember
what ah oh I didn't know this was
actually gonna be a place that I could
go in oh nice clown this is lovely
this is good stuff I so he never came
back
no sir and he didn't take his phone
either all right and what time did your
husband leave the house what's that all
about probably me if I had to guess only
me if I had to guess there's some like
the chemicals that the planner causing
some vivid hallucinations I'm not sure
it was late though my son was listening
to this old radio play called dread when
we left okay great
I love radio plays about dread what am I
seeing as that scary Garfield what kind
of twisted gallery is this look gallery
of nightmares in my whoa hey bud James
Gary Gacy was sent into death for
butchering 16 young female prostitutes
having grown up in a broken home he was
never known his biological father Jim
was hanged for his crimes in 1903 I
don't know why that needed a save point
but I got a bad feeling about James
so all oh no oh no I should be running
now I should be running but I'm not
running okay we're okay
well I mean we're clearly not okay but
you know we're what
who's there no one no one no reason
you're a tall one great what happened
what happened to me where did I go okay
good yeah that was um normal yeah normal
okay so I'm guessing I got lead him on a
loop-de-loop so I'll lead him on a
loop-de-loop all right here we go again
I'm gonna lead him on a loop buddy loop
and I gotta go the way he came from
right okay let's dance fancy pants let's
dance pants pants
let's go fan spins come on where you at
oh you got nothing what's that you got a
whole lot of nothing oh that's right you
got nothing I forgot you don't have
anything you got nothing you got nothing
on me
oh you're kind of quick oh you're a
little quicker than I had previously
anticipated I know you know but they
were supposed to be an ex down there
hello oh I had my chance that I lost it
maybe I don't know
all right cool anyway hey you ladies
want to help me at all no okay so it's
not that here does not the exit as I've
discovered turns out it's just a dead
end so where am I going oh crap oh crap
oh [ __ ] ouch ouch it's fine totally fine
I'm going back up to the top for reasons
that I can't explain and I actually well
oh okay I didn't know I was on a timer
there was something over there the shiny
thing a triangle the Triforce and I
missed it crap it's locked and there's
no keyhole either how does it get locked
then strange any ideas if it's locked
then that means there's electricity
still on see a wire so if there's a
generator or something which will open
it yeah more like a control panel cool
tight tight cool tight cool tight sick
tight super cool ball and tight sick
tight nasty you were right it's a
control panel full of buttons we still
need a specific key though I'll find it
new take this what a manual I'm sure
you'll figure it out I hope it's worth
it alright let's see aha
what did Oh what did I just saw so bad
in here of course they're too calm about
this
what it Liam quite field station was
flooded due to its closeness to Hidden
Falls was having a widespread effect on
the crows Mills subway system which is
experiencing power outages in its
stations opioid overdose deaths have
increased by 4% crystal data storage
technology is making its way to the
market that was not helpful at all I
don't know why 7 9 23 3 Wow gas eruption
at the metro station 47 injured it was
caused by the explosion in the Iris's
underground laboratory just below the
Stillwater Asylum of course it's just
below an asylum three out of four
patients were found dead major Crowe
resigned from his post Irish
pharmaceutical biotech secret
experiments revealed the old iris
underground lab and four subway stations
affected by the explosion now officially
declared a restricted area yeah I'm
guessing they're some kind of chemical
leak in the air look Sid what was that
can we get a playback of whatever that
was
please can I get a playback whatever
that was okay why were you leaving Oh
Poochie
he's Boise Boise boy hey you leave him
alone doesn't seem to work Liam hurry do
something
Liam hurry do something Liam please I'm
trying look here young Greek thank God
I guess that crisis was solved just give
me the key and let's get out of here all
right all right don't know where that
dog came from Oh daddy well the good
news is that we're almost out of here
yeah we should hang out more
that'd be great you know that Blanc
comes out tomorrow we could play it
after school or something you didn't
have any plans after school did you know
cool where were you from again me blank
and do you have any friends left there
no I mean not really I bet you've never
been to it at the abandoned subway
tunnels before you're right did you tell
your parents about it I did actually
you know I would have assumed that these
guys judging on their pictures were like
in their twenties maybe early 30s
apparently they are in school seriously
my father would have never let me go for
such an adventure in fact today I'm
supposed to stay at home studying good
thing I left a stuffed doll of me a
mannequin like recreation of me my
parents will never know the difference
I only have one parent that's me and my
mom this is pertinent to the daddy
hangman game I'm sorry no it's fine he
didn't die or anything he just left us
sometimes I wish I didn't have a father
I'm like it's so boy this daddy issue
o'clock okay sorry again that sounded
awful is it so bad kinda
is that why you're staying in the club
until the school closes all right this
should be station let's look around
oh that hole has been plugged man this
is going so many strange places I I
really it's like you all very weird okay
all right don't give up I think don't
give up
that's don't give up got it don't give
up so remember don't give up and then
another hole in the tree which I'm sure
is going to be good and definitely
answer all of the questions that I have
nos come via spooky I shouldn't touch
that I should not touch this I touched
it did you see my child you know no I
didn't no I did not I didn't see your
child mr. bear trap a hunting we will go
a hunting we will go we'll catch a fish
and put him in addition never let him go
okay
yeah no butthole that's a bottle a
hunting we will go a hunting we will go
we'll catch a fox and put him in a box
never let him go well these are cheerful
really jovial really nice a hunting we
will go a hunting we will go will catch
a pig and dance a little jig and never
let him go okay
hunting we will go a hunting we will go
will catch a bear and cut his hair and
never let him go
okay so there's numbers assigned to this
is 4 so bear is for pig is 2 so pig to
bear for I think fish was 1 that would
make Fox number three fish Pig Fox bear
fish Pig Fox bear I'm guess butthole
sing sure hunting we will go a hunting
we will go will catch a fish and put him
in addition never let him go hunting we
will go a hunting we will go walk out
y'all pickin that's a little jig and
never let him go a hunting we will go a
hunting we will go we'll catch a fox and
put him in a box and never let him go
a hunting we will go on doing we will go
we'll catch a bear and God is there and
oh no no what are you hey a hunting we
will go yeah my right or am i right a
hunting we will go a hunting we will go
heigh by you I see around I can't leave
so did you run away from me oh yeah you
scared of me I don't like your face I
just want to say that oh crap
you didn't touch me so what do I do oh I
got a lead into the trap of course it
seems so obvious
[Laughter]
alright good you were right I guess it
wasn't so saved after all I'm sorry it
wasn't your fault
he clearly shouldn't be jumping on it
just like you said right but I can't
help but feel responsible for each of
you that's sweet but maybe you shouldn't
now that I think about it it was kind of
funny sorry for being such a drag
sometimes you must be sick of me already
just a little bit Hey but really thank
you without you guys I wouldn't have any
adventures that's nothing so have you
applied for college already I did not
come on why not
it'll totally accept you it's
complicated
what what's so complicated about it it's
about my mother
No I'm sorry I didn't mean to is it
serious it is actually didn't I tell you
no I don't know anything
I'm just saying that blank can we change
the subject please a course okay maybe
you won't be able to leave the town but
you could study here right it's not
exactly what you're looking for but
Aaron please I don't know the whole
story but you have to keep please just
stop okay sorry
push push push push
I really shouldn't it's alright I
understand
I'll support you regardless of your
decision really shouldn't whine what are
they talking about I don't like your
face I don't like your face at all lady
I just have to say that I don't like
your face hi hello well I came did you
see that no I didn't see anything what
are you talking about what you see what
camera
I saw a moving QP no really okay I
wanted to show you some are those keys
from the joy shop my mother used to work
here so I don't know you think it's safe
seriously gotcha
of course let's check it out this is
even the conversations are weird and it
may be because this game is like
translated from another language very
bizarre what was that what did I just
see what ritual whose beard did they cut
off light sabers light swords I hate
clowns
yeah I think most sane people do
definitely why are we here what we don't
excuse me what have we done to deserve
this
what if we done what sins have we
committed crunch
all right couch what's all this junk
looks like someone lived here yeah I
wouldn't be surprised okay that's
nothing yeah definitely that's not that
yeah it's it's all on a refrigerator is
that a bed what are all these looks like
hospital equipment do you think that
someone's living here let's get out all
right cool um great good stuff I'm gonna
I'm gonna go cry I think this is so
bizarre this game is so weird but I love
it like I love it I'm so into it like
the the the conversations are a little
disjointed but honestly and I think it's
just because a translation thing but it
honestly serves for the story
everything is weirdly disjointed and I
think it's like trying to piece together
someone's memories it's so weird and
scary too like it's it's creepy I'm like
this whole time my skin's been crawling
I don't know this game is weird how have
I not heard about this oh no it's cool
I'm gonna keep playing this game I am
definitely gonna if you guys want to see
more of it stay tuned subscribe for more
ring the bell like this is like seeing
I'm not crazy right this is cool right
okay cool
I thought all right cool we're on the
same page he makes games you next game
he makes game he made me again you see
he made me get low game for my birthday
special anyway alright so thank you
everybody so much for watching
look forward to more of this because I I
don't even care if there's like no
payoff at the end of this so the way the
game is playing is just really fun for
me I like it a lot check out the other
scare games that I played in this
Kherson close another RPG maker horror
games and stuff like that
and uh yeah thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]